[Music]
welcome back to careful boys everybody
we have with us a very valuable guest
today
say hello to ron hi ron
hi rod
last time we had ron here was for ask
the expert and it was kind of a a a
bittersweet kind of time too because you
were talking about like man
fighting's over i'm just going to train
i'm just going to help coach but in
between that this dude became a [ __ ]
champ congratulations thank you thank
you
kick kick boxing chat wbc
lightweight national muay thai champion
it's a pretty big deal it's a pretty
[ __ ] big deal how did that happen
knocked him out that's how it happened i
thought you did i thought you gave up on
life yeah i thought you gave up on
fighting you're like i'm a dad now
i'm retired i thought you were depressed
and then you're gave up and then i think
you started listening to smashing
pumpkins and then they're like 1979 yeah
i was like i wish i was born in there
tired of this [ __ ] see that's why i say
don't listen to smashing
smashing pumpkins or smash mouth don't
you're smashing puppies listen to smash
roth more actually
because you're an all-star okay
don't listen to nirvana
that's it don't listen to yeah nirvana
don't listen to any of the 90s early
2000 rock bands because they're going to
unmotivate oh
is dashboard confessional for them is
that the difference they're all sad yeah
maybe green day what's been going on how
did you get into get the title fight and
how did all this stuff happen uh
randomly i was kind of just training on
and off a little bit and then trying to
get once i realized ufc really wasn't my
kind of wasn't really had the chances
that happening weren't very probable
anymore why not why is why is not um
because you change yeah cause you train
with a lot of ufc level fighters
and in the gym you go toe-to-toe with
them so you're at the level but how come
you're not science because my age i'm
getting a little older i'm 36 now so you
know if you don't love 36 at all thank
you what's the normal like average age
to at that point to be like oh it's
probably not going to happen about 36
oh the perfect age if you look at all
the ufc champions now like usually your
career peaks at 35 36 oh you know so
like henry all these guys they're all in
their 30s but um for them to bring me in
there kind of doesn't make sense because
like all right we're going to build this
guy and he's only got what a few years
left you know it's kind of i get it
doesn't make sense business wise but i
mean
there's always a chance for me to still
get in it's very slim but i definitely
started shifting my focuses elsewhere
how did the the muay thai like
opportunity land on the table uh they
randomly called me
i think they couldn't find any opponents
for the the current the current champion
at the time and so they called me and i
was kind of in shape but for me like i
just need like three months of focus and
i could probably get in decent shape and
then so they hit me up but the only
reason why i got the offer in the first
place because we met a we made a bet
with a promoter and so like three four
years ago i fought one of the contenders
in the u.s uh marvin majiyaga he's
killer he's freaking awesome but you
killed him maybe
[Laughter]
his tombstone's at rose hills
i was just there a couple days ago
we uh we went to his hometown in san
diego and uh
everybody was there for him like
everybody i brought like 40 people with
me oh he's a hometown favorite he's the
hometown hero like he's the freaking man
um
and we made we made it wages like look
we know what you brought us in for you
brought us in to die
um we want to get paid for it and we
want to put a wager if my boy wins my
coach was talking for me i'm not allowed
to talk to the negotiations
that's how the fight game works right
like the fighters don't really talk as
like ages and coaches promoters will
literally just ignore me and they and
not acknowledge my existence and just
make eye contact with my managers yeah
now it's different now we're not best
friends but uh
so he's like i'll make a wager don't put
this in there
he's like we'll make a wager if if if
ron wins what happens if he wins we want
a title shot and then
yeah and without hesitation he's like
okay sign the contract and then boom
just like that uh got us the amount that
we wanted and then gave us a title shot
if we won did you crush that fool yeah
yeah ultimately won by uh ko in the
fourth round um so it worked out knees
elbows uh punch elbows it was bad you
like elbows huh i love elbows
don't tell my next opponent this
i try to chill down my spine when you
said that this video is all they need to
beat you yeah they're fighting like this
watching it now we know the secrets yeah
it's over
don't get elbowed
um so yeah i mean we got that
opportunity but uh we didn't get a phone
call
until
like randomly in like last year sometime
and i got a phone call i was like hey
ron
you've been training i was like not
really why he's like
you want to fight for uh the wbc titles
like heck yeah i'll be in the gym
tomorrow dude that's awesome yeah so it
was tough i had to let my family know my
co-workers know all my partners know
because like they had to pick up all the
slack for me because then usually i'm
working like every day and so uh wifey
was down to hold down the fort uh watch
the family while i put time in the train
all my partners picked up my slack when
i wasn't in the office so i could train
and then um you know everybody's been
super supportive so i did like a full
three-month camp and i felt
freaking better than i ever have in my
life it was freaking sick
but it what i found that was kind of
therapeutic because i like fudge i think
i'm missing this aspect of my life
because i was feeling like a fire yeah i
feel like a lot like i didn't see it but
i felt normal like first time i left
because you're meant to be a warrior
phone
yeah i felt freaking normal man it was
weird like from samurai to samurai i
understand what you did
yeah you know i felt responsible like an
adult
providing for my family like i'm doing
what i'm supposed to do but like deep
deep deep within i'm like you need to
punch somebody yeah i'm not fulfilled
i need some sort of violence or
something i don't know already full-time
run like running your own business at
that point where you had to like yeah
yeah at that point uh i was i actually i
was in the gym maybe once a week or
every couple weeks just to just to have
some sanity uh but then i was just kind
of just working i was like my whole life
was like i don't want to be in a cubicle
and type buttons and then i ended up
going to wealth management office got my
own cubicle with buttons and i was like
i don't like this i gained like 15
pounds i've got these tailored outfits
so i look all sharp and they don't fit
anymore what if we just get you really
big buttons that you have to punch
like have you seen the kung fu panda
game at dave and busters i win the
jackpot every time i freaking love that
game i've seen it is it the boss comes
by so you're gonna have to leave sir
yeah they cut you off yeah
you're gonna have to go to the
basketball game we know you suck at that
i was like don't you move sir
now i'm losing money
but uh yeah then i got into wealth
management for a little while and then
that that wasn't a good fit for me and i
was lucky to get that and then i got i
got offered the opportunity to go into
towing and then i went to that full-time
and then that whole thing how did that
even come you know it's not even come up
like dude pandemic changed my freaking
life man it was yeah pandemic changed
everything because before what was it
like before and how did it change before
pandemic i was just training all day all
night you know just living the fight you
were managing you were teaching your
training yeah doing everything fitness
and wellness related possible and then
pandemic hit and we had to shut down the
gym which is dude do you remember when
you had a shutdown barbell is that the
most surreal thing yeah we at first when
the pandemic came i was like this is a
joke we're closing our gym they're not
gonna make us and then we gotta come we
got a letter from the state saying you
have to close i was like they just made
us close i was like shoot yeah it's
crazy i couldn't believe it yeah so
i was
i was jobless for like like two or three
months i was like fudge uh what do we do
so one of my students was a flipper so
he started having me flip sneakers i
didn't get the sneakers until i met him
and then the issue with sneakers is you
start selling them then you start liking
them and then you stop selling them and
then you start buying them i'm like
now i'm losing money again it was a trap
i was like dude this is sick people this
is working you got some dope shoes on
too man oh but no these are done yeah
this is these are my go-to shoes these
all i wear now i got the i got a whole
new thing where i was like all right i
got too many toys i need to calm the f
down so i sold everything i have like
nothing oh i got a couple things left
but um i got rid of everything i
literally wear the same thing every day
now um
and i'm trying to get my wife to do it
but you know it's a little harder yeah
oh she's a girl girls are different so
what things did you say you flipped
besides i flipped sneakers
um i flipped hair clippers so during the
pandemic you couldn't get a haircut yeah
the barber shops are closed so what do
people do they cut hair at home and you
know has the best hair kits costco they
had these
the 72 piece kit for 40 dollars and we
had an inn
with somebody in there and they let us
know when the shipments would come in so
we'd camp out in the mornings and buy
pallets of them because it's costing
sale you can buy them at wholesale so we
bought them and we flipped them on ebay
for 100 to 150
wow people were buying them because
they were sold out at costco everywhere
everybody wanted them and then
who figured out that like algorithm like
my my buddy shot he was just he worked
out of clippers he worked at costco and
you know what's funny as we started
camping out at costco to get these
clippers other people like us were also
camping out at costco it ended up being
like this whole thing and people were
getting there before us or they had a
bigger end than us and ended up wiping
out the inventory before we even got
there
yeah i was like oh fudge so we got
kicked out my friends from high school
during the pandemic hit me up and he was
like hey bart you own a gym right i'm
like yeah he goes do you have uh access
to gym equipment i'm like oh you're in
the fitness industry he goes nah i just
want to flip gym equipment it's [ __ ]
crazy right now it is people just doing
that pandemic was such a weird short
period yeah of money grabs for people
people just flipping things they know
there's premiums on stuff it was crazy
people got creative too
i bought my weight set like so if you
went to like dick's sporting goods right
the whole weight set was like under 200
bucks but i bought it for 700 bucks
doesn't say if you're buying weights
during pandemic you're rich man yeah i
got to do deadlifts
did adjustable dumbbells for like a
thousand dollars everywhere today's
video is brought to you by audible so as
you guys know
i don't live here mm-hmm like joe i
don't either yeah i live in vegas
and uh my favorite thing when i'm
driving because now that my
like i work from home i work out from
home i don't have my normal errands
anymore so i actually really look
forward to driving because that's when i
get to start listening to stuff podcasts
audiobooks and on audible right now i'm
listening to psychology of money geo
actually put me onto this and it's
really cool because it's talking about
how a lot of people they they view money
as this thing that you have to like
attain and it's like this object and
it's like sacred but the people that are
good at investing in finance it's
actually your behavior around money and
how you perceive money so that's super
cool so now i get to listen to it and
what's amazing about listening to stuff
i noticed in the same amount of time
like let's say i spend three hours
reading i don't retain as much
information as if i listened
and that's why i really enjoy audiobooks
and if audiobooks aren't for you audible
got all kinds of other stuff podcasts
uh theatrical release type stuff guided
wellness a whole slew of original
content as well so if you want to try
audible all new members get 30 days for
free just go to audible.com
off the record or text off the record to
500-500 to try audible now i i couldn't
get into that time because everything
was done but you know the the
best-selling items were hand sanitizers
and clorox wipes oh yeah those were a
hit in new york when it hit when the
pandemic hit the hardest people were
buying these like six pack of clorox
wipes like right there for like freaking
like 200 bucks and it's only like it's
worth like 25
like it was
it got so bad that ebay and all that had
to start regulating it saying that you
couldn't sell essential items
and so all these all these flippers
started getting stuck with all this
inventory right
i remember that yeah it was the price
gouging yeah price scale that's really
no more yeah can't do it no more crazy
time so if you got in that window where
you could do it
oh man oh my price got so good
hair clippers you're like gouging yeah
dude the hair clippers was freaking
crazy and then i got into inflatable
pools because everybody everybody wants
to swim in their backyard and so they
just inflated the pools from costco it
was like a 30 inflatable pool sold them
for like 250 bucks
and people were buying it people were
meeting me up on offer i was like i'll
give you 300. i'll give you 350. my kid
needs to swim i was like okay my
friend's pretty badass like he um he has
this huge video game distribution
company and when the pandemic hit like
he got really into a non-profit like
several years ago and he's like this is
more rewarding than business and then
like when it hit right we're just
talking like oh man what we what can we
do to help because like i'm not a nurse
or whatever and then we started seeing
all these things about like
they don't have masks they don't have
gloves they don't have all these things
so we're like oh [ __ ] maybe we should do
that so i created like a little
fundraiser and all that he found a
hookup and then he realized like
hospitals have money
but
they have to get it from their like
certified mask
distributed retailer or whatever so they
couldn't get it at walmart they couldn't
get it at daiso or whatever right so
then um what he did
is
he spoke to one of these major retailers
and he said look before you guys release
this to the public
give it to me i'll buy it at retail
price so you don't have to sell it to
your like retailers and don't put it
online because they're going to price
gouge like all these people are going to
buy it and sell it to people on the
streets for [ __ ] up prices i want to
buy it and i'm going to give it to
hospitals and i'm going to give you the
publicity and then he's like
they're like so every day they're just
like hey we need a freaking you're not
buying enough you're not buying enough
so like even though we did like a
gofundme and all that stuff so he's like
i don't i can't even buy this with my
own money so he got in contact with
[ __ ] like
like fema or some [ __ ] like government
agencies and then he broke brokered the
deal between them and he directly got
masks from them to give to doctors and
nurses and a lot of these places he was
saying like you had to give directly to
the nurses and doctors if you dump it
off at the hospital some of these
hospitals are like they'll just hoard
them and they'll put them away and
they'll lock them up or they won't
receive them because they're like well
some of them have different reasons like
one would be like we can't take anything
from outside for legal purposes some of
them be like for pride and image and
marketing they're like our hospital is
like top tier we don't need these things
or whatever yeah it's all [ __ ] up and
then so at the time nurses were using
the same mask every [ __ ] day taking
it home
it's and then like they're already
getting sick or they had coveted and
they're it's like so [ __ ] up so then
we had to give it directly to the doctor
directly to the nurses and they're
passing it around like that yeah they're
shortages all kinds of stuff it was a
crazy time a long time dude this was a
crazy crazy time like i felt like i was
a fugitive because i was running outside
remember you weren't allowed to go
outside yeah
there's a curfew but dude you live in oc
and it's a complete different place
because i remember when la was like
super messed up i went to go buy a
mountain bike in orange county and out
there
they looked at me weird for having a
mask on and they're like you mastered
dude we went to go we went to go eat pho
during the pandemic oh we sat down yeah
in the beginning though everyone was
freaking out because nobody knew what
the heck was going on so in the
beginning i would sneak out and run into
the trail i lived a space called penis
canyon and i would sneak out there and
be a ranger camped out at the entrance
to make sure people wouldn't go in the
trail it was so redundant and spread
covered while jogging oh yeah i remember
the trails would be taped up
and i remember when they first removed
the tape when you go on the trails like
the grass was crazy growing in and you
saw so much more wildlife yeah because
they were used to like humans not being
there for a while dude i remember at the
beginning of the pandemic there was the
bioluminescence at the beach in like
southern california and that was the
only thing people could do but we went
to manhattan beach and they blocked off
the whole beach they wouldn't let you
cross the the
boardwalk yeah and they wouldn't let you
go on the beach at all to look at the
bioluminescence remember they dumped
sand on the half pipes and [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] you and they took the sound they
dumped it on the skate park so no one
would be cause it was when everyone was
freaking the [ __ ] out yeah like we're
all gonna die so let's put sand on the
skatepark
that will make them safer
[Laughter]
[ __ ] was crazy that was a logical thing
to do in oc there was a park right and
they they taped it off with caution tape
but you see just kids playing there
anyway yeah they hopped over it yeah i
took videos of my kid uh just playing at
the playground and then i always put
caution tape like in like the background
so you can see and always play that
cough steam bad boys
it's like yeah you play on that swing
like a freaking like a criminal
so uh tell us about the towing business
you got into yeah oh yeah so i did all
that stuff and then
um
i started selling gummy or and then i
sold gummy bears
just regular gummy bears yeah so yeah uh
sugar bear hair and so it's just like oh
thing that makes your hair grow or
something and does it really work
i don't know
i never i never took it how did this
even happen how's that the whole
flipping thing imaging yeah yeah and uh
so it's they don't want to sell to
anybody and so we ended up having a
connection in the middle east we had to
smuggle it um in the middle east because
you can't you can't bring anything in
there in iraq they don't let you they
don't let anything or anything go in or
out of the country but we had somebody
that would smoke not drugs freaking
gummy bears they had somebody that would
smuggle us goods into iraq and sell it
at a premium wow so
i ended up landing the account
and we bought like 70 000 worth of gummy
bears what the [ __ ] yeah we shipped it
to freaking iraq and it made it in and
they ended up selling like so the bottle
for us wholesale was like 15 17 bucks
dude for a little bottle of gummy bears
it was pretty it was like small it was
like half the size of this bottle what
if it got confiscated you guys would be
out 70 cheese no because we already sold
so we we sold it to a guy and then that
guy would smuggle it in and that guy
would sell it to the retailers in iraq
so you just have to salt to the guy
so you don't have to market it or
anything
of the hands yeah we have the access wow
no wonder you don't know if it works
it doesn't matter yeah okay i wonder if
that kind of smuggling can get you in
jail maybe out there i'll get you one of
these
they'll probably kill you can i rather
you're still smuggling even though if
it's not like crack i'm assuming the
smuggling has to do a lot with bribing
out there
i don't know but there's got to be
there's there's always that's the
international language there's like the
baldest guard
hey you want to enter there girl
don't worry so how did that
how did smuggling gummy bears turned
into toe trucking because the guy that i
was smuggling gummy bears with was in
the towing industry
and then he was like it's always i was
like thinking okay
why is an asian dude getting into a toad
trucking because the middle eastern's
got that locked down yeah he's nearly
sick
so that's like that's like if an
armenian guy started a nail salon and
i'm like
wait a minute that's a vietnamese thing
you know is your wife vietnamese like
what's going on so i'm like how the hell
is he getting into a tow truck thing and
i'm like well i guess it's just wrong
you know it's just run run because i was
just gonna try ron [ __ ] you know and i'm
like interesting so that's how you got
into that's how i got it with my buddy
shai yeah he brought me in and then um
the the group that helped us out kind of
held our hand and kind of gave us
one-on-one training to how to optimize
the industry and how to do it the right
way so we bought a tow truck him and i
we worked seven days a week we did
12-hour shifts and then how'd you guys
know it was going to be a good thing he
promised me it would be
i promise you bro hey i smuggled i
smuggled gummy bears for you dude it was
it was it was on paper the the riskiest
decision i've ever made because at that
time i was like i only had so much money
left and i dumped it all into the
venture he's like do the gummy bears no
no no no the gumbears all the money made
from the gummy bears the flippings are
gonna make money money on shoes
ultimately we got some cool kicks that's
a true entrepreneur i got a pretty cool
collection
but you lost in shoes you gained in
style yeah yeah and now i don't even
wear them i'm making a point to wear
only these shoes every single day i got
i got my my unicorn pair i ended up
getting a pair of travis scots
did you really the one that looks like
the mocha did you stab anybody for it
because that's how people had to get
them no i bought them on stockx okay
you got it that way yeah i bought on
stockx and uh
all the profits i made from the shoe
flipping
was pretty much just that shoe that's
awesome how much is that shoe it was at
the time it was like 1300 bucks or
something god damn yeah yeah it's a
fancy shoe dude now i don't even wear it
it's just probably worth more good don't
wear it go sell it i can't cause i threw
it well i didn't know this you're
supposed to keep boxes and stuff
for stuff you collect yeah i threw i
threw them all away no way
i have the laces though fire that's so
good
somebody will still want to buy them
yeah
so yeah i mean my uh my friend chad was
like i just had a feeling he was like yo
this is going to work it's going to cost
it's going to cost like 200 grand to get
this and to get into the industry to
start just to start that doesn't even
include the truck that's just to get no
but now you guys have like how many
trucks yeah yeah so i ended up working
out um dude wifey thought i was freaking
crazy she's like are you serious this is
everything that we have left and then
how to borrow money to make this happen
and she's like sure there's a good move
i'm like this is it unless we want to
live the same life forever which we
can't it's not sustainable uh we gotta
we gotta make moves now yeah and this is
it you know and then so she's like okay
let's do it i got your back i was like
awesome that's a dope wife
she's down how many trucks do you have
so we started with one and then we got
another another another and now we are
at uh we're at 12 vehicles whoa whoa
i didn't expect you to say 12. i thought
you're gonna say like three of them are
service vehicles so they don't count
they're just like trucks and priuses um
you want to know a quick business hack
to get more trucks just tow other tow
trucks
i don't know where you're going buying
them
like a sucker
and how what was the time from truck one
to truck 12 uh how long
we are at month nine months nine
years
holy [ __ ] it's been freaking crazy dude
dude good for you that's so dope
i'm not killing it i'm not million or
anything like that because all the money
yeah is going back but which is smart
that's how you do it yeah yeah you guys
like ko trucking yeah ko towing recovery
yeah yeah cause we knock out every job
you know
wow
is that is the logo or elbow
pointing at us and him going
don't tell anybody
the secret to my fighting is in the logo
now i need to change my logo
dang it secret is out it's a secret side
my career is over thanks guys jk news
has ended my career
it's there the whole time it's uh it is
fight related though it's a boxer doing
a dump not that a boxer do that it's a
double bicep flex pose yeah and then
like two toe trunks behind it and it's
red white and blue because we love
america
nice
that's awesome dude yeah
thank you yeah that's huge we just
started we have two more trucks coming
um that we're building um oh yeah tow
trucks you have to build i mean you can
buy them but they overcharge you but you
know how to build those what's the
starting platform regular truck like a
f250 or f350 or a dodge 5500 that's
considered light duty so you start at a
5500 yeah 5500 is generally what you
should start out with they're all
dualies or yeah yeah they got to be
because the stuff where tone is like and
there's different types of tow truck
builds no there's you got the one with
the [ __ ] crane
you got one with the flatbed one with
the crucifix looking yeah yeah there's
two there's two main ones there's what's
called a uh a wrecker or a wheel lift it
lifts
two wheels off the ground and then
there's a motor carrier or a flat bed
and that's the ones that everybody sees
everybody requests too yeah everyone
everybody wants a flashlight especially
the low boys yeah what's your favorite i
like the oh so
i like the wheel lift because it takes
more craftsmanship
more technique yeah it takes more
technique you have to like have you guys
do you guys remember that top gun game
it was like old nintendo game where like
when you would fuel you have to like
line everything up otherwise you would
like miss the hole and you see the axis
and like yeah yep that's uh that's
towing in a wrecker so when you like
back up to somebody you have to like
yeah
and if you're off you like hit the car
or you miss or whatever so you learned
how to do that after you went all in on
this business you didn't know how to no
yeah i didn't even uh do the first three
months with the sketchiest ever i was
like almost hitting other cars like i
couldn't even turn like i've driven
trucks before but these trucks are huge
and so i'm not used to the turning
radius cars are honking at me and like
what happened was your partner he knew
how to drive it though and run it yeah
he taught you how to do it he had a few
months more experience than i do
are you just watching youtube tutorials
while you're dude
i go all in on everything i youtube
i was like
youtubers
[Laughter]
today we're going to teach you how to
tow this truck it's the same boring
voice guy that shows you how to use
[ __ ] photoshop too yeah all right
guys you're going gonna want to back up
pretty slowly
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you